usa eroberten mittelamerika ja was
erobern die usa eigentlich nicht das ist
ein spiel und du verlierst gerade das
spiel imperialisten date corporation
blöder amis können nichts oder fast food
und krieger anfang nicht bald katheter
jetzt endlich wirklich ziehen das jetzt
durch ja nie wieder disney-filme keine
pepsi kein mcdonalds jemand mcdonald's
gesagt der flugschein usa
mit freundlichen grüßen oder leck mich
am arsch kapitel 1 die spielen immer
noch cowboy war wirklich das einzige was
die usa zur welt gruppe beigetragen
naja ein bisschen mehr schon jazz pop
art zombie filme de burgh und meditieren
vorrüstung mehr aus als china die ganze
eu und russland zusammen die für ein
geständig krieg in vietnam oder
nicaragua die befreien
alle länder die nicht so leben wie sie
leben sollten
in den letzten 100 jahren gab es nicht
einen einzigen präsidenten der nicht mit
truppen irgendwo einmarschiert ist oder
die stationierung von truppen fort
geführt hat
die usa kam ihm aber gibt es nur
irgendwie chicken nuggets aber irgendwer
muss das machen wie viele diktatoren
wären ohne die usa noch an der macht
wenn die weltpolizei gegen ihn hier
nicht eingegriffen hätte würden wir
heute wahrscheinlich alle braune händen
tragen
aber wie viele diktaturen sind denn wege
in den usa immer so bei napoli obama in
acht jahren insgesamt 2663 tage lang
krieg gefühlt hat mitgezählt
dieses western gehabe und das ist doch
heutzutage einfach nur noch dumm diese
dinger hier sind nichts anderes als
massenvernichtungswaffen und woher kommt
der ganze zauber fetisch gehabe und lass
mich an einer weisheit teilhaben von den
verdammten waffen kapitel 2 deren
waffenrecht ist der größte unsinn der
weltgeschichte völlig egal wie viele
revolver sturmgewehre in manchen staaten
dass sie da einfach auf der straße haben
im supermarkt kinder dürfen mit echten
waffen am schießstand das doch krank ich
bin es auch scheiße und für deutsche
waldorfschule prinzessin in venedig ist
das schwer zu verstehen aber das ist in
den usa hat ein wichtiges grundrecht das
recht waffen zu besitzen steht bei denen
seit 1791 in der verfassung die mussten
sich ihren start erst gegen den staat
england erkämpfen
und da haben die sich gesagt vielleicht
muss man sich mal wieder gegen den staat
wären und dann ist es doch gut wenn ich
nicht erst umständlich knarren verteilen
muss sondern jeder schon eine unterm
kopfkissen hat hierbei western von
gestern aber war das schenken dem ndr
das war vielleicht vor 100 jahren
sinnvoll aber ganz ehrlich wie oft muss
ich mich denn heute vormittag um
jemanden duellieren oder eine miliz
gegen den staat gründen
naja wäre bei ihm hier vielleicht auch
nicht schlecht gewesen
es ist leicht auf die doofen amis immer
runter zu gucken aber für die sind ihre
waffen so heilig wie für uns das recht
auf rasen ein generelles tempolimit auf
autobahnen kriegst du in deutschland ja
auch nicht durch tempolimit eine leiche
das schlimmste ist dass sich an diesem
bizarren waffen sind auch jetzt weg ist
nichts ändern wird
ich meine was macht das mit der
gesellschaft auch psychologisch märz bei
den amis ständig amokläufe 20 20 hatten
über 16.000 tote durch schusswaffen
ich bin aber in ihrer parat was bei mir
ist das okay ich bin deutscher kapitel 3
dass wahlmänner system ist wählen für
dummies coffee to go ist wirklich das
einzige was die usa zur weltkultur
beigetragen werden naja ein bisschen
mehr schon im blues hollywood
superhelden allein das bescheuerte
wahlsystem
ohne das wäre trotzdem nie ins weiße
haus gekommen
schon fünf mal ist der kandidaten mit
weniger stimmen präsident geworden
hillary hatte fast drei millionen
stimmen mehr als doppelt ja das klingt
total bescheuert aber aber auch das hat
historisch gesehen irgendwie seinen sinn
gekommen
anstatt einfach alle stimmen zu zählen
gewinnt jedem bundesstaat einer einzeln
und dieser staat schickt dann wahlmänner
nach washington wahrscheinlich heute
noch umfährt
ohne das elektrolyt college würden aber
ganze bundesstaaten irrelevant werden
die auf dem land mit weniger einwohnern
die bräuchten gar nicht mehr zur wahl
gehen weil die wahl nur in den
ballungsräumen entschieden würde das
system ist kompliziert und ein bisschen
ungerecht aber so hat auch die
landbevölkerung eine stimme ordentlicher
zehnte lang auf so eine partei wie die
csu bestimmen wer bei uns ein
verkehrsminister und mit mal warum ist
eigentlich immer bei uns ein paar
verkehrsminister warum ich meine jetzt
mal ernsthaft warum cola ist ja das
einzige was die usa wirklich zur
weltkultur beigetragen haben naja ein
bisschen mehr schon das skateboard dlp
das internet amazon netflix die
mikrowelle die solarzelle der
herzschrittmacher ja es herrscht selbst
verstanden so schlimm sind die also gar
nicht ja und zum glück ist auch am
renten- beiden sind zwar nicht obama
aber das ist ja dann halbwegs
vernünftige sein werden
kapitel 4 der donald ist tot es lebe der
damit die soziale spaltung amerikas ist
ja immer noch da 70 millionen amerikaner
haben noch 'mal trump gewählt und dass
es nicht nur ein us problem auch bei uns
ist populismus längst der neue freche
kek getrennt
ich glaube wir hassen die usa auch
deshalb so weil wir da immer unsere
eigene zukunft sehen ach was bei einer
mit bavaria und beim pariser
klimaabkommen es war super
nord stream zwei unsere gerd schröder
russen pipeline findet beiden genauso
scheiße wie trump die zeiten wo wir als
kleine süße deutsche entspannt unter dem
schutz des großen bruders zählen konnten
sind vorbei
wir müssen uns eine klare haltung zu
china überlegen unsere
verteidigungsausgaben erhöhen und mehr
militärische verantwortung übernehmen
[Musik]
also militärische war wurde kann ich ja
gar nicht dazu gedient untauglich rücken
ich auch religiöse gefühle
[Applaus]
[Musik]
youtube ist das einzige was der usa zum
weltkulturerbe beigetragen haben
am 20
[Musik]